[Music]
in the world's most powerful country a
sharp turn away from right-wing populism
the inauguration of democrat joe biden
donald trump became the first outgoing
president in modern u.s history not to
attend
but two weeks before the inauguration
many of trump's loyal supporters
attacked the united states capitol
building in washington following an
unsuccessful bid by trump to overturn
his defeat
today
we celebrate the triumph not of a
candidate but of a cause
the cause of democracy
the people
the will of the people has been heard
and the will of the people has been
heeded
for the first time a biracial woman
kamel harris was elected as the u.s vice
president ushering in what many see as a
milestone
across the atlantic the end of an era
after 16 years of leading her country
and europe german chancellor angela
merkel decided that it was time to step
down
after general elections she was replaced
earlier this month by ola schultz a
social democrat
this coming year could see more changes
in europe
incumbent french president emmanuel
macron is expected to face strong
competition in april
the leader of the right-wing national
rally party marine le pen has launched
her third bid for the presidency she too
faces stiff competition from a far right
candidate eric zemer who has been
compared to donald trump
in hungary right-wing nationalist victor
orban has held office as prime minister
for the last 11 years and in april he
too will face a strong electoral
challenge
2021 was marked by an alarming number of
coup d'etats and growing
authoritarianism
there were coups in mali and guinea a
military takeover in sudan an
unsuccessful coup attempt in niger and
an arbitrary transfer of power in chad
in the new year kenya and angola will
hold general elections and mali will see
if the transitional authorities do in
fact hold elections as promised
in the middle east syria's president
bashar al-assad obtained 95 of the vote
in a re-election that was widely
described as fraudulent
while in iran ultra hardliner ibrahim
ricey was declared the winner in an
election that saw the lowest turnout in
iranian history
in latin america 2021 was a turbulent
year with nicaragua's leader daniel
ortega assuring his re-election last
month after disqualifying and arresting
the vast majority of his would-be
competitors
but in neighboring honduras cio mata
castro the wife of a former president
who was ousted in 2009 was elected as
the country's first woman president
[Music]
the year ended with a 35-year-old former
left-wing student leader gabriel borrice
elected in chile with the largest number
of votes in history
there's no indication that the region's
more authoritarian governments will be
less so in the new year
but after a decade-long swing to the
right the election of gabriel borrice in
chile could signal the beginning of a
new shift back to the left in the
continent starting with latin america's
largest country brazil
the new year will pit populist
conservative president jayed bolsonaro
against his arch political foe luis
inacio lula da silva brazil's left-wing
former president whose prison conviction
for corruption was overturned in april
and was now leading in the polls
but they will also compete against the
man who sent lula to prison former
anti-corruption czar sergio moro
colombia could also shift from the right
to the left in may polls put former
bogota mayor gustavo petro in the lead
south korea will hold presidential
elections in the new year
but perhaps the most attention will be
on the philippines where current
president rodrigo duterte could be
replaced by ferdinand marcos jr the son
of the country's former dictator and
duterte's daughter sarah who's running
as his vice president there's concern
that the ticket aims to perpetuate their
respective political dynasties
lucia newman al jazeera santiago